thank you I wish I could just stay at my
old place but I can't afford the new
rent yeah moving sucks you know
strangers handling your belongings the
movers always break something oh no I
can't afford professional movers moving
myself this Saturday man you can help me
with some of the big stuff yeah you know
what I've been thinking a lot lately and
I think we need to spend some time apart
not not to break up no I just I just
think just some time time apart to
figure ourselves out and and and then
and then we come back together stronger
you know this is coming out of nowhere
no it's not
I've I've tried to tell you like I'm
like a million different ways but you
don't listen see that's the thing is
that you you never listen I don't need
this time apart for me I need this time
apart for us how long do you think it's
gonna take you to move okay this is
about the move you don't want to help me
move I would love to help you move
that's what boyfriend's do Claire I just
think that it's a weird coincidence that
you need space right when I'm about to
move oh my god oh my god I am so sorry
that I didn't plan my emotional turmoil
around your move look at look at your
face see and now you've assumed the
worst of me because you do that and
that's what we need to spend time apart
from each other that is not fair but all
I'm asking for is 12 lousy hours this
Saturday okay fine okay [ __ ] fine
we'll move on Sunday 48 hours I don't
know what I was thinking 12 hours it's
nowhere near enough time to do what I
need to do to make our relationship
stronger see you got me all
confused and you know what I love you
but I gotta get out of here I can't I
just can't I don't I'm so confused right
now I feel like I can't think and the
walls are closing in on me I just don't
know what to do
what's my landlord he says he doesn't
wanna lose me as a tenant so he is not
going to raise my rent now I don't have
to leave my place and I don't need time
apart
because we're perfect together
[Music]
will you marry me
you paint my apartment of course I'm
painting your apartment of some
boyfriend's do we when exactly do you
think that's gonna happen
you